the nominees for the best picture of the  year are Chinatown a Robert Evans  production paramount Robert Evans  producing the conversation a directors  company production paramount Francis  Ford Coppola producer Fred ruse  co-producer the Godfather Part 2 a  Coppola company production paramount  Francis Ford Coppola producer gray  Fredricksen and Fred Roos co-producers  Leni a Marvin Worth production United  Artists Marvin Worth producer the  towering inferno i'm throwin allen  production 20th Century Fox warner  brothers or when Alan producer  and the winner is Godfather Part two  parentheses  I'd like to thank a fabulous crew that  worked very hard to make this picture  what it was and thank you to all of you  thank you very much there were 127  actors and actresses in Godfather Part 2  and they all deserve to share on this  honor thank you thank you again we tried  to make a film that would be a really  good film and-and-and thank you very  much thank you